you want to talk about the difference
between Showbiz and politics here and
the overlap Rhonda santis
who I think is the greatest governor in
the country right now Ron DeSantis
just put out a political ad
where he Compares himself to Top Gun
morning ladies and gentlemen this is
your Governor speaking today's training
Evolution dog fighting taking on the
corporate media The Rules of Engagement
are as follows number one don't fire
unless fired upon but when they fire you
fire back with overwhelming force does
it say that in the bill I'm asking you
to tell me what's in the bill number two
never ever back down from a fight if I
could complete the question though so
you're going to give a speech or ask a
question number three don't accept their
narrative it's wrong it's a fake
narrative I just disabused you of the
narrative and you don't care about the
facts it's why people don't trust people
like you because you peddle false
narratives alright ladies and gentlemen
don't know
[Music]
[Music]
as much as I love Ron DeSantis and I
really love the guy
he's as much as I hate this ad I hate I
whoever
whoever suggested this ad to the
governor should not only be fired but
should probably be imprisoned okay
that's how
bad this ad is because the ad
totally Cuts against the whole DeSantis
ethos
the whole DeSantis Vibe is that he
doesn't need to put on a soft shoe in a
show and talk himself up and and make a
big spectacle of himself because he's
just really good at governing
that's the the whole argument for
DeSantis over Trump in 2024 is that
DeSantis has all the really good
qualities of trump he attacks the media
he's got the right end stains he's right
on the issues but he's much more
effective at wielding political power
I'm not saying that's even necessarily
true I'm just saying that's the argument
for DeSantis over Trump
and then DeSantis goes out and makes one
of these kind of cringe-worthy
commercials
that undercuts that whole argument the
whole argument for DeSantis is he's a
serious guy no he's he's not messing
around he's not one of these clown
politicians that just goes up and does a
little routine in a little Vaudeville
number and doesn't really do anything
the Santa's the guy who gets stuff done
he wields political power he's a tough
guy and then they haven't put on a clown
suit and dance around what is wrong with
these people ah
these you never
never underestimate the ability of
Republican political Consultants to
clutch defeat from the jaws of victory
DeSantis needs to just
forget about this ad politicians make
mistakes but just
he he needs to be aware that he doesn't
have to do this stuff because he's the
real thing he's the real deal
he could just be the real thing he
doesn't need to be the pretend thing
it's it's the Meghan Markle problem
Meghan Markle was the real thing she was
an actual princess and she gave that up
to try to play Disney princesses
she she was an actual public figure
royalty the real deal and she gave that
up
to just be the kind of image of a public
figure to just be a facade to just be
someone on a TV screen
to just play pretend we don't need to
Ronda Santos doesn't need to play
pretend he's the real thing we all need
to stop playing pretend
and we need to actually do stuff
we're living it's a it's a technological
and social problem it's a problem of our
age we're all just living in virtual
reality
we're all just playing pretend we're all
pretending that that we're a certain
identity on social media I'm not even
talking about media figures or
politicians all of us are doing that
we're putting out a pretend persona
instead of doing the real thing
we're taking photos that are totally
specially tailored to make it look like
we're having a great time instead of
just actually having a great time to
make it look like our lives are really
perfect instead of actually working on
the habitual virtuous things that make
our lives very good and that lead to
human flourishing
don't do that just be the real thing
speaking of potential presidents
you know how much I hate to say I told
you so you're aware of that
for the past couple of weeks
there has been chatter among the libs
there's been endless wishes and the
whole political class they've said Liz
Cheney might run for president in 2024
Liz Cheney so
ending up against the trumpists and the
Maga the Liberals on ABC News not just
ABC news but there they are I think
representative they were just discussing
all the very serious commentators with
their serious Ties on and sitting on
network television and they said Liz
Cheney oh boy she's going to pose a real
problem for Trump she's going to play a
real significant role in the Republican
Party
Mark what what is your sense on the role
that she has
taken on I I think she has been look I
would say that she's Unleashed but she
was pretty Unleashed before the election
but I think she will be an extremely
relevant figure in her party I think
across the board I I think she seems
like she is one committed not only to
sort of take down Donald Trump but to
take down the sickness of her party
extremely relevant the Republican party
she's going to take down Donald Trump
she's going to take down all the Maga
people so that's what the the genius
political experts were saying
on this show six days ago
I said the opposite I said no Liz
Cheney's a joke if she ever runs for
president she's not going to take down
Trump she's not going to be relevant the
Republican party if she does anything at
all she's going to hurt Joe Biden
so what's her support Nationwide among
Republicans I don't know negative 10
percent
she would be a spoiler for the Democrats
because the Democrats have gone
completely insane
even the majority of Democrats know that
they've gone completely insane the
majority of Democrats don't want Joe
Biden to win in or to run even in 2024
and because the Democrats have pumped up
Liz Cheney as this honorable Maverick
Rogue voice of reason I could see a lot
of moderate Democrats
possibly pulling the lever for her
in 2024 so find by me Liz I truly truly
hope she runs
she will not be a problem for the
Republicans
guess who was right
guess who is Right you've got the whole
stupid political establishment of
experts who are geniuses who go on
network TV on one saying one thing
then you've got little old me
little old me in my little old Studio
saying the opposite guess who was right
turns out
I Told You So a news new report from
Yahoo news and yougov shows that Liz
Cheney if she were to run for president
in 2024 would not only not take down
Trump she could single-handedly swing
the election to Trump by hurting the
Democrats this fall and yeah it was
Yahoo and yougov so these are left-wing
polls they found
that if there were a one-on-one rematch
between Biden and Trump today Biden
would lead by Four Points among
registered voters 46-42
now I don't really believe that that
would happen but that's just to show you
that the poll is skewing to the left
in a three-way race
with Liz Chaney on the ballot Trump
would flip from being four points down
to having an eight-point lead over Joe
Biden 40-32. why do I bring it up do I
bring this up just to toot my own horn
no no not just to do that I bring it up
to remind you and I'm preaching to the
choir here
the people that our society exalts as
experts are complete idiots who don't
know anything or who are intentionally
misleading you they are wrong about
statistically everything
they are wrong about Liz Cheney they
were wrong about Trump they were wrong
about Russia collusion and Ukraine's
collusion we always forget about that
they were wrong about remember net
neutrality repeal all the experts said
that if we repealed net neutrality
people would die remember that they're
wrong about that's just one kind of
random example they were wrong about the
vaccines they were wrong about the masks
even YouTube's they're wrong about
everything and they're wrong about
everything and so if you continue to
trust them on anything
I can't help you you're not gonna make
it and I know I know that even for us
hardened conservatives who we don't have
really any trust in the establishment
anymore but even for us when you see the
fancy people in the fancy Ties on
network TV and they've got really fancy
faces you know and they look really
serious
they say Liz training she's going to be
a really relevant figure in her party oh
yeah global warming is going to kill us
all in nine years uh-huh oh The Masks
totally work they super duper work uh
the vaccine if you take the vaccines
you'll you'll never get coveted and you
won't spread it and we're really serious
people it's it's hard to
it's hard to push back against that
because
they are they at least have the facade
the veneer of authority
they don't have any real credibility but
it sort of seems like they do I had this
experience I may have mentioned it on
the show I went to my 10-year College
reunion and I got to see a lot of my
friends some of whom are former friends
because they don't like my political
activities in recent years
but I would say probably a fifth of the
class we had a nice time hung out had a
good had a good time and a lot of the
rest of the class not only were they
frowning at me but they were frowning in
general I noticed this a lot of a lot of
my classmates I went to a very liberal
school and a lot of these people have
gone on to have
according to the New York Times
according to the kind of elite consensus
they've had really
good lives they they did all the things
they were supposed to do
they went to the fancy school they
didn't settle down and get married they
worked in some kind of
liberal company that that is considered
prestigious they didn't prioritize their
personal life they they moved to the big
city they lived in a little pod they
went to all the restaurants that you're
supposed to go to they only prioritized
work and they read the New York Times
and they read the Atlantic and they just
did all the stuff that the liberal
establishment tells you to do and all
the experts tell you to do and they lock
down
they wore the masks and they get all the
shots and they
they take all the advice of the libs
and they're miserable
so many of them
you look at feminism the feminism which
is one of the most effective political
movements in American history certainly
of the last 50 60 years
feminism said we are going to make women
happier
ever since feminism took over in the
1960s women have become much less happy
both in relative terms to men and in
absolute terms
it didn't it's not it doesn't give you
what it promises it will give you the
experts
the emperor has no clothes the experts
have no wisdom you really should not
believe them I'm so glad you like that
clip now you got to subscribe ring that
Bell we hit a million subscribers love
that we got to hit a billion head on
over ring that Bell get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
oh
foreign